all right so we could do the money thing
for the the whole remaining time here
and way longer than that but I want to
shift to something else which you've
said a couple times you're not making a
judgment call on the Democrats or
Republicans and as I said at the intro I
find you to be one of the few people
that I consistently see calling out both
sides I see you get hate for it you know
and you just said it's like any time you
say something about Trump the Hillary
people's get angry and then of course
the the same goes the other way
is this a new phenomenon I know everyone
you know politics is about picking a
team but do you think it has gotten
significantly worse this time around
because even if I joke if I do make a
joke you know Star Wars reference the
Trump looks like Jabba the Hutt then I
have to make something about Hillary or
like it's really gotten crazy yeah I
definitely think politics has become a
lot more tribal I mean that's the term I
use for it which is it it doesn't matter
what we're fighting about we're just
simply we're just simply fighting and we
we have the parties have defined
themselves almost exclusively as not the
other party regardless of of the fact
that operationally speaking on in many
in many cases the parties or at least
the party leaders when it comes to votes
and policies they agree on a lot I mean
this is the thing that's that's
hilarious to me is you know you see
these yeah I think was it quick Chris
Wallace or one of the moderators and you
know the parties really disagree on you
know there's so many things the parties
disagree on and actually there are not
that many things that the parties
disagree on like they're just darn I
mean the parties do not disagree
basically in any kind of deep
fundamental way and I'm talking about
the core of the parties here they do not
really fundamentally disagree on defense
spending they do not really
fundamentally disagree on America's war
posture in the world they do not
fundamentally disagree on issues like
surveillance they do not fundamentally
disagree on what you might call
corporate subsidies the subsidization of
private industry and private
corporations and that's
you know that's a huge set of issues
they do not fundamentally disagree on on
in any kind of really major way on taxes
I mean there are some disputes on
specific taxes and you know but but in
terms of genuine structural taxation
issues there there's not a fundamental
disagreement there's not really a
fundamental disagreement on free trade
among the party leaders leadership that
may be changing though that out there I
mean these things are you know all fluid
I think there are some disagreements on
health care but but on you know we tend
to think that there are these
disagreements because the media defines
stories political stories and narratives
as only those issues in which the
parties disagree that it's not really a
story when the one you just went out
when there's a Senate vote that's 97 to
3 that doesn't tend to be a big story
because there's no conflict there even
if the policy itself is absolutely
enormous so so I I think that that that
in in lieu of major many many major
policy disputes tribalism has taken over
where it's basically just about power
it's just two factions that agree on
lots of things and maybe have some
disagreements they magnify there they're
the relatively few disagreements in what
is really not a battle over a policy but
as a battle purely over a tribal power
and and I think what's changed is that
maybe that's always been that way among
the actual individuals empowering of the
Senators the Congress people the
president the party officials what's
changed I think is that that tribal
attitude has become the activist
attitude that is a difference that that
the that the motivating force at the
activist grassroots level has been
inflected with a kind of tribal my party
or the highway or you're with us you're
against us regardless of what
policy were you been discussing at the
activist level that you can actually I
mean I'll give you an example that
sticks out to me in the presidential
campaign Trump has been pretty I would
say articulating the same themes that
many principled progressives have
articulated on the issue of trade and on
the issue of social security you know he
has been more articulate about the
problems of NAFTA than most Democrats he
sounds more like Bernie Sanders than
anybody else when he talks about that
issue now you can say it's not genuine
but just let's go rhetorically yeah he
has been the only Republican that I can
remember my whole lifetime who gave a
speech saying you know we cannot cut
Social Security cannot be touched like
absolutely not I shouldn't even talk
about you know privatization and you
haven't seen at the activist level or
even among kind of left publications any
recognition of that at all I mean you
haven't seen that much you know afl-cio
if it was a principled organization you
could say look we're still with Hillary
Clinton because there's all these other
issues that we agree with believe in but
you know what this is a big deal that a
Republican presidential candidate is
articulating the same things that we've
articulated on the issue of tricky you
haven't seen that because it because at
the activist level or at the you know
the sort of the the the level of the
groups that are supposed to be based on
principle they too are now inflected
with this tribal sense of you're either
with my party or again so you've got the
afl-cio bashing Trump on trade even as
Trump is articulating the afl-cio s
basically their rhetorical position on
trade
you've got the afl-cio prioritizing
purely prioritizing a kind of partisan
argument and and I'm not saying that I
don't understand the calculation they're
making a power calculation but the but
the problem is is that if you strip out
the principle from the groups from the
activists that are supposed to be the
players and politics that are based on
principle they're not supposed to be
like the politician who's just in it for
power
then you've debased the whole process in
a way that makes it even more difficult
to have honest principled arguments
about actual policies yeah and yeah I
love that you're bringing this up and
laying it out so clearly because this is
what I've been trying to explain that
and I like that you're also making the
distinction Trump may not be genuine in
what he's saying which is my biggest
issue with him I don't know what his
moral Center is but if were to just go
up what he's saying the irony here is is
that he doesn't want a nation build so
he's really crushed the neocon movement
a lot of the neo cons are gonna go with
Hillary right
he also completely annihilated the
Christian conservatives who are still
supporting they're like his main
supporters at this point but we know
he's not a real supporter of the
Christian conservative movement or their
values and then you take Social Security
so a lot of the things in a weird way
he's the most moderate Republican there
is where if we could have ended up with
a Rubio who would have probably been for
far more you know foreign policy
adventures or Cruz who would have been
more in bed with the Christian
conservatives so again we don't know
because we don't know the truth place
with Trump well I mean usually you just
yeah I mean I start from the position
that I assume that almost every
politician is purely an opportunist
seeking power and that they will change
their position at any time if it's
better for them to sit for power that
even principled politicians in a lot of
cases they have simply they have a more
defined view of what their opportunity
for power is and that that that's
sticking to a principle actually is
their opportunity I mean that's a
realized a very cynical view so so what
I am discussing here is not you know is
Trump genuine or not genuine does he
really mean it would he really be for
social security where he cut it if he
was president I mean I have no idea
because he's an opportunity he'll change
I have no I have every confidence that
he would change his belief system and
position at any time because because if
he saw an opportunity and that just like
I believe that about about most
politicians the point is is that there
are supposed to be actors in politics
power players in politics and certainly
activists in politics
who do not subscribe to the ends justify
the means
purely for tribal power that when that
that I would like to believe I don't
want to idealize the past but there used
to be at the activists and you know
nonprofit NGO political activist group
level the the focus was we are going to
advocate for this set of policies
regardless of which party is for or
against this set of policies and if we
have allies and in both parties that's
great if somebody's saying you know on a
b and c issue that we don't care about
or that we're not organized to kick in
our group is focused not on a b and c
that person may be terrible on those
issues but if they're good on you know x
y&z that are our issues we're going to
actually try to build you know
legislative or policy bridges to them
that where the principal is the most is
the organize the organising force there
are supposed to be power players and
politics and at the activist level where
that is the priority and i think that
what has changed is that there is less
of that now that the activist space has
become more more adhering to the power
for powers sake
yeah you know it's interesting the ends
justify the means thing sort of brings
me back to where we're at with obamacare
right now where we're seeing now these
double-digit rate increases and it
reminds me of window but when this was
all happening and obama said you know if
you like your plan you can keep your
plan even though it later came out that
he knew that wasn't going to be the case
so he was clearly doing the ends justify
the means i want to pass this thing so i
have to lie to do it i personally and i
suspect you do you're not really an ends
justify the means person and that and
that is really what sort of it rots the
underpinning of everything else cuz then
it's like you just don't believe any of
this i think that's what is really
fueling the Trump thing people simply
don't believe anything and this will be
a good good segue to talk about the
media a little bit which which you give
them some [ __ ] to which is nice do you
who do you believe at this point because
I flicked this stuff all day long and I
go I mean this one's a [ __ ] artist
this one's married to that politician
this one ran his campaign
this one's on the payroll for that
campaign I mean if the whole thing just
is a circus
well look here's here's how I read the
news I mean who do I believe I mean one
I tend to read a lot of the business
press because the business press is
written for people who are trying to
make money and so the business press in
some ways has less tolerance for
[ __ ] than other parts of the press
that if your subscriber base needs you
to be accurate in order to make
investments in order to make money then
and that that subscriber base has no use
for gossip and stuff that's not
important then arguably it's going to be
sort of more just the facts ma'am kind
of kind of reporting so I rely on the
it's not to say that there's not problem
to the business presently the business
press gets you know they have a little
bit of a you know they sort of
worshipping their own thing captive
worshiping their own sources and the
like but I read the business press I
something I don't you know I'm not one
of these people who a hundred percent
trust much of anything but this is the
kind of you know I kind of have a
portfolio of things to try to get at
closer to the truth I
so I rely on that in the political space
look it's very hard to trust anything
you're reading that is not document
based because stories that are not based
on hard documents already can tend to be
subjective if I go out and I go to a
trump rally I can and I'm gonna talk to
ten or Clinton rally and I'm going to
talk to ten random people I may have
talked to ten really weird people I may
have talked to ten really representative
people it and the story I tell is of
either rally is in a sense inherently
subjective because I I didn't talk to
all 10,000 people there and there's no
real way to do that so what I tend to
trust the most are stories that are
based on indisputable facts indisputable
documents things that people we know
they've said or we
no they've done or you know actions that
they've taken that can be demonstrably
proven to me that's a way to at least
get to a part of the truth and frankly
there's not a lot of that out there
especially in the political arena
there's not a lot of that out there
because that's a lot harder to do it is
a lot harder it takes a lot more time it
takes a lot more patience it takes a lot
more work to do stories that actually
dig up documents indisputable facts I
mean you know taking up you know sources
who provide you know sort of tangible
evidence of things that is a lot harder
to do and we have a media environment
that that basically rewards a hot takes
that basically rewards anything that's
so-called you know clickable and so you
know in a certain economic perspective
if you're if you know we've got a
journalism business that when faced with
hey somebody can write you know take an
hour and write a hot take that's just
their opinion on something or somebody
needs to take two weeks to find you know
this or that document - - that shows us
where a politician may be on an issue
that affects millions of people and a
somewhat esoteric issue you know the the
business model will say have the person
have that reporters spend the hour doing
that don't have them go you know spend
the spend the time and energy to really
do the hard work of real reporting and
so we are immersed in an ocean of of not
only I would say a lot of vapid
political content but political content
that that in a sense you can't trust you
can't trust it because a lot of it is
not based on on anything that is
objective indisputably tangibly true it
is a lot of subjectivity that's not to
say that that that all subjective
writing is not true
but it is to say that it's harder to
trust something when somebody is
basically saying here's my opinion and
here's my analysis and here's my view
versus here's the document in which that
public official said this or
this and you can argue that I'm that I'm
not presenting it right or I'm I'm
presenting it in the wrong light but
here is the document that is the most
powerful form of truth that is out there
right and I can say firsthand I know
that everyone's chasing the clicks and
the money and things like that because
look the way we do this we spent our
whole first half hour talking about
money in politics I know just because of
the YouTube algorithm talking about
money in politics it's gonna you know
depress our views had we spent you know
a half hour talking Trump grabbin [ __ ]
with David Sirota
you're gonna get a lot of views so
everyone you know does what they have to
do but I think that's an interesting
point you're making about actual
documents so when it comes to WikiLeaks
as far as I've seen there the the
Democrats are trying to say that a that
Putin is involved with Trump doing this
which I don't see any direct evidence of
or that that Trump or you know that wick
that Assange it basically wants Trump to
be President you know it's a lot of
conspiracy stuff but as far as the
document as you're saying the actual
written stuff is there any evidence that
any of it is not true that you know of
because that's another point that people
keep saying well that some of it could
be forging bah-bah-bah I don't see any
evidence of it and I have been able to
come up with it I haven't seen any
evidence of it I know that the Clinton
folks want the questions to be to be to
be out there and they're you know the
this is what they're good at
I mean you want to talk about the
Clinton machine Clinton aides what are
they really really good at they're very
good at taking major big issues and
turning them into small esoteric tribal
fights they take the big and turn it
into something small so the big in this
is here are all of these documents
exposing major policy preferences and
and political issues that can affect
millions and millions of people and
let's turn it into this much smaller
fight for you know cable TV chat shows
about well the Russians released it or
they didn't release it or they're behind
it and some of its not real and you know
so we're not actually talking about the
actual big stuff we're talking about
the very you know sort of in terms of in
terms of importance we're talking about
the relatively small I'm not saying the
small stuff I'm not saying that you know
if the Russians were involved that small
what I'm saying is right we're not
talking about the issues that affect
millions and millions of people right
content of the stuff right we're not
that's what they don't want to talk
about and so what they've not been
really good at doing is I think they
recognize that they can't go out and say
these are not authentic I mean I've seen
why you know her pollster was on TV and
sort of sort of more explicitly
suggested that but for the most part the
the Clinton team hasn't said you know
these are really not authentic people
the officials around Hillary that have
not said that but there's been a subtle
hint of that though I feel right
instantly yeah right they know they
can't go out and explicitly say that
right but they want to to have questions
about the authenticity bubble and
percolate out there and you look you see
you and and and in some ways their their
tactic is working you see you know you
know on Twitter on Facebook you know how
do we know these documents are authentic
and my answer to that is look as a
reporter it's always it's always hard to
kind of prove a negative you know are
all ten zillion emails authentic I mean
I have you know III haven't gone through
all of them right but here's what I know
that if one of those documents was could
be demonstrably proven to be not
authentic the there is there are plenty
of politically powerful well resourced
political actors out there who would
make that very very and very very public
the fact that that has not happened is
really an indication that that that that
these are almost certainly authentic
because the the Clinton campaign if they
found one email that they could prove
was not authentic which would which if
there was a for Jeana it really wouldn't
be that hard right then the all I need
is one and that would be it like that
then all the questions would just burst
out there and and all of the of the
documents would be called into question
do you think the biggest risk related to
WikiLeaks is the
one thing that it seems to me nobody's
really talking about now I've said with
as far as WikiLeaks you have to view it
with the skeptical eye because obviously
there is a political agenda the way
they're releasing this stuff as it gets
closer and closer to the election
there's some political agenda they have
is it coordinated with Trump as you'd
say I have no evidence of that but okay
to me the biggest risk of WikiLeaks is
not that we're gonna get all of it
before the election but that potentially
Hillary could win and they've really got
some stuff that they saved to either
release after the election which would
be a massive blow to our democracy or
that they could potentially blackmail
her with now I don't like going down the
conspiracy route I know there's plenty
of that on YouTube but do you think
that's a legitimate concern because I
pretty much I'm seeing nobody discuss
that and I think it could be possibly
the the biggest issue here that they've
got some bombshell that they're just
gonna hold for their own purposes maybe
to ultimately use her and then she'll
have to go I gotta go to war or drag the
only thought through it you know like
Assange wants you know XY and Z is he
gonna you know hold some document and
try to get her to provide asylum or
something like that yeah i you know i
I've been focused more on
the contents of the documents I mean I
think you know the idea that something
would be held until after the election
that would have been germane to the
election look that's already happened
right I mean with the with the you know
if they if the emails had come out or if
the if Clinton's team had released the
wall street speeches there's an argument
that says that the Democratic primary
turns out completely differently I mean
I I definitely think that the Clinton
team has proven ends justify the means
in the sense that if something bad or
politically inconvenient comes out after
we've already secured power where where
what has been revealed is not a threat
to us I haven't seen any evidence that
you know that things can then be
resuscitated to become then politically
problematic once that political hurdle
has been jumped in other words something
that may have been problematic
that had to come out in the Democratic
primary has not proven to be
particularly problematic at in a
political sense in an electoral sense
for Clinton in in the general election
now there's a you know you could say
well the media is blacked-out WikiLeaks
and you know I mean I said yesterday I
mean it's amazing to me I mean you want
to talk about you know sort of death of
journalism stuff the New York Times two
full pages on Donald Trump's tweets now
you know just republishing his tweets
that happen a couple days ago and and
I'm not saying that I'm not even going
to make a valley judge around that maybe
that is legitimate you know here's
everything everybody he's he's he's
insulted but where are the two full
pages on all of the policy revelations
about policies that affect millions of
people that were in the WikiLeaks emails
where where is the times two full pages
on that could it be ever happen if they
don't want to out their own friendlies
that are in the WikiLeaks as we can
well I think there's that right
identical that's work at the New York
Times yeah I think there's you know I
think there's the media is uncomfortable
because it does expose the WikiLeaks
stuff exposes that but I also think it's
like this calculation that readers care
about kind of salacious and insulting
tweets and maybe won't care about you
know the ins and outs of Hillary
Clinton's you know telling Wall Street
how she feels about regulation which i
think is both condescending to to
readers and that's and that's a you know
that's a that's a benefit of the doubt
kind of view and I think there's also
that the media doesn't view what is in
these documents on a policy level as
particularly problematic and that's the
real disconnect here is that you've seen
a lot of the reaction to the WikiLeaks
documents be well there's nothing new
here there's not a lot of news we
haven't we know she's friendly with Wall
Street but like that's I would argue
that maybe all normal and fine and not
news to people who operate in the elite
political class but it is news II and
noteworthy and important for thousands
hundreds of thousands millions of
readers who that is not normal for that
is that is a revelation I do look I do a
lot of reporting on pensions and I'd
hear all the time we'll do a you know
over the pensions and investments and
how Wall Streeters is
is is grabbing pension money and you'll
talk to people on the inside of the
industry said well that's not really
news I mean that that's happening all
the time and then we published our story
you know reader regular readers like um
I had never heard of that no idea that
was going on and I think the elite media
exists in its own bubble where it is
deciding what's news and what's not news
based on a very insulated elite bubble
perspective that is not the same
perspective as its as its potential
readership out there yeah and then when
you add to that that there obviously is
somewhere at least in my opinion there's
some political element that the New York
Times if Trump's emails had been hacked
they'd be all over the front page of the
New York Times so they might have some
political allegiance II would say take
it further yeah I mean take it even
further I mean this is where it gets
really depressing is that if it was
Trump's emails these same groups the
same left liberal progressive groups
yeah that are saying hey nothing to see
here and not anything you know there's
nothing interesting here would be all
over all over it yeah you know and that
speaks to what we talked about before
which is that there's a lot at the
activists kind of nonprofit level it has
become it has now also become a tribal
view as opposed to a principled view
yeah listen David I wish we had more
time because you really I mean people
the number one question I get asked is
who do you trust who's calling out both
sides and I consistently tell people you
so that I hope that everyone will follow
you it's at David Sirota on Twitter and
I suspect your work is just cut out for
you it's just at the beginnings again
because this thing's only gonna get
crazier so thanks so much for doing this
you